laughs
um so Jeanette McCurdy apparently is now
doing all like the TV show interviews we
got her you think
nah yeah doing a lot of the Performing
the tap dancing of like the the smile
and the showing up and landing on my
mark and I'm gonna
just do what I need to do and be this
you know happy-go-lucky Nickelodeon kid
it's been a while I mean it's been years
since we've Revisited the whole Dan
Schneider stuff right
but
um
she wrote this tell-all book I am going
to skip specifically because everything
everything I already watched this whole
thing so everything up until the point
that I'm going to skip to is just your
typical growing up a child actor is hard
right okay okay
that was this is a nine minute and 48
second interview okay this is with the
uh now we get to the
the part that we care about the Snyder
stuff so it's important for me to step
away in a very definitive way
and really just focus on completely on
healing myself reflecting back on her
career Jeanette's critical of the
Hollywood Machine and the world she was
exposed to at such a young age which by
the way we all agree with in her book
she writes that after Sam and Cat was
canceled Nickelodeon offered her a 300
000 thank you gift if she agreed to
never speak publicly about her
experience at the network
Nickelodeon offered Jeanette this is the
first time this has come out public
right we were remember I I only know
this because I wouldn't normally
remember this but because I went back
and was because I was you know
re-uploading old clips I was kind of
listening to when I was re-uploading
them
we said this right this is something
that we said ago they're probably
offered all these people money however
specifically with a man she refers to as
the Creator who on one occasion she says
encouraged her to drink while she was
still underaged and gave her a shoulder
massage in response Nickelodeon telling
ABC News we have no reportable response
other than a no comment at this time so
yes
so yes but here's the thing Jeanette
McCurdy never took the money
I just said no it's not happening that
sounds like hush money to me not doing
it Mine by the way you got to remember
something this [ __ ] was 18 years old
when she said nope I ain't doing it you
know yeah I've taken it and then I do
remember
leaning against I think I talked about
this in the book but I lean against my
bed and I'm like I'll shoot I could have
put my nieces through college like that
was some good money but I am ultimately
proud of of my decision there
um wherever it came from even if it was
informed by self-righteousness I think
that uh I think I did something that was
really hard to do oh my God it makes
emotional I'm proud of myself
why why I beat I'd be more Pro here's
here's the thing and here's my problem
and you don't ever want to be the guy
that attacks the victim I'm not trying
to
but this is frustrating and I'll explain
why so our guests always up until I saw
this clip our guess always was that they
were not talking because they were given
an NDA in hush money right we've always
said that which made the most sense of
course however now we're finding out
that she did not take the money so she
said no I'm not going to so
three things I want to point out here
one
Man Child Actors age terribly and I am
sure it's because of all the [ __ ] they
have to go through in the drugs they get
on that I do feel bad for her for that
uh you know because the first the easy
thing is to go like wow she looks
terrible but then you're like dude her
life was [ __ ] really [ __ ] up number
two
okay I'm so proud of you Jeanette
McCurdy for not taking the three hundred
thousand dollars however
why then are you calling him the Creator
and not no pun intended saying his name
um
good
probably because
she doesn't want to get dragged through
[ __ ] courts and [ __ ] I mean at the
end of the day number three
why isn't this journalist
so who's this Creator is he still out
there doing this to other people no
you're ready journalists should at least
ask even if she says I don't want to
talk about it I don't want to no that's
what I'm saying give her a chance to say
I don't want to talk about it Go all
right well I did my job as a journalist
I asked she only has done two interviews
that I found since her book came out now
she's not saying his name but now I know
what you're saying and I've thought
about that she doesn't want she doesn't
want to get dragged or whatever okay
number one
she's already said who it is without
saying his name there is no other
Creator there's only Dan Schneider for
these shows it only says created by Dan
Schneider okay so it's him obviously
it's him we all know she's talking about
him so at this point and I always say
this in for a penny right like you're
already saying it you might as well say
it
that's the part I don't understand why
isn't she saying it and let's say here's
here's okay check this out
if this ABC News was doing a hit piece
for example let's say on a right-wing
person it could be any person right
they if if I would have said oh yeah you
know the the if if I would have said uh
here's a great example the the the the
fat the founder the default one of one
of the biggest hosts on The Daily wire
who's Jewish actually called me a [ __ ]
and I were and then somebody were to go
to me hey but who was it clearly it's
Ben Shapiro but I didn't say it the
media would have then said in this part
and you know I'm right because we've
seen enough news stories they would have
said
she does not elaborate on who the
Creator is but the only creator of
iCarly is Dan Schneider and put a
picture up of him but they didn't
so this is still [ __ ] weird right
like it's weird but
look man it's it's her credit at least
she's saying something and I mean she is
saying I'm not criticizing I'm not I'm
not criticizing I got it but then you're
saying the cover-up but they've already
done this because they're all complicit
right because who's interviewing her by
the way um I I think it's I don't know
man I don't know the reporter's name the
Asian or the Viacom Company uh no this
is ABC no this is Disney okay this is
actually yeah but Disney Disney doesn't
want to get in a [ __ ] sling and war with
Nickelodeon and all molested kids either
I I hear you I hear you I hear what
you're saying that makes sense I get it
but I'm just saying it seems weird
everything is weird look it takes a lot
for her to say anything I [ __ ] get it
I know it's easy to be the edgy guy and
be like oh what are you scared you
little bit no honestly this [ __ ]
sucks for her and I think you're right
nobody won but then she probably
shouldn't have said anything like either
we're doing this or we're not like this
is kind of like a middle of the road
kind of thing that we're doing doing
here right make some money I'm proud of
myself unless unless unless unless
unless
behind the scenes her lawyer is doing
some sort of financial or some sort of
suing Nickelodeon for something and her
lawyer said don't say his name yet
that's you know what I'm saying that is
very possible right because you don't
want her to be oh you want a news and
you slandered him before you went to
this court case you know what I mean
only thing I can think of but still
doesn't make sense but whatever so
why why proud of yourself
I think I've chosen
to dress like Paula Poundstone for the
rest of my life
I'm gonna dress like somebody who's been
molested yeah
bye Paula Poundstone
there you go huh take that Paula
well well well you think you think Paula
Brownstones ears are ringing
were you gonna do shoulder pads
dressing like Andre 3000 I'm talking
about treating this with the gravity it
deserves well first off
I think we're treating it way better
than we normally treat things so
honestly joking aside I think we're
doing pretty good
I don't know treating it better than Dan
Schneider treated her that's [ __ ]
good point that's true or the way the
media treated her for like five years
yeah at least I'm not making you stick
your foot in your [ __ ] yeah that's a
really good point
heads
and it hasn't always been easy again I'm
saying this I'm not because I know
people are going to try to misconstrue
this into like why are you going I'm not
going after her honestly what merch
brought up is a good point my biggest
gripe is with the journalist right now
right my biggest gripe is with the
journalists because the problem is
you're right
here's the thing debt Schneider is
currently not doing anything right now
he just stopped one of the most
successful producers Nickelodeon is has
Dan Schneider took Nickelodeon when it
was struggling because it was struggling
for a little while there and he made
these little teeny shows and everybody
watched him and they're [ __ ] huge and
they blew up and they're the biggest
thing Nickelodeon had and they threw all
the money at him you're telling me if
Dan Schneider hasn't done anything wrong
or anything questionable you're telling
me that right now Dan Schneider hasn't
worked
in Hollywood since the since all this
stuff started coming up since the last
Nickelodeon show he did was years ago
that's weird imagine if the one of the
quote-unquote best creators for
children's programming is just sitting
there and this he's not throwing money
at him for a job right nobody's throwing
money on account all the race and that's
my exactly
and that's my point
and that's my point yeah the worst part
is the hypocrisy to me it really is you
know it really is and people you know
there's got to be like one executive at
Disney that was like Hey what if we hire
Dan Schneider and one of the guys just
went what the [ __ ] do you think this is
the good old days yeah exactly yes yes
hey hey hey hey Bill yeah does he make
it after hit yes is he a [ __ ] machine
of money you better believe it but it's
post Harvey Weinstein [ __ ] the
old days of hiring creepy producers that
are super talented are over so now what
you get is mediocre warp garbage made by
Indian women do you hear me that's what
we could make yeah you'll sooner see a
goddamn Bill Cosby special on HBO before
Dan Schneider ever walks in this office
[Laughter]
do you [ __ ] hear me
now 30. Jeanette says she's recovered
from years of eating disorders and found
this okay so that that's
um that so now I wanted just to compare
something here
then she did good morning she's on her
complaint tour she did Good Morning
America and I want to see we and now
she's dressed like Sailor Moon for some
reason we're gonna skip the okay here we
go this is the part that we need to get
to here we go
we're in 2013. the former TV star
writing about her mom's controlling
habits from calorie counting her
daughter's food which triggered Eating
Disorders from a kurdi to her mom giving
her showers until she was a teenager
yeah sounds like the president
um what
what
her mom gave her a shower so she's a
teenager big deal why oh I don't
understand well to watch Dan Schneider's
come off of her I don't understand the
need of like like if I heard that about
like she what she's got away with it
because she's a mom but like could you
imagine if a dad yeah he'd be the
president
I mean I know we're living in Biden
world but I mean could you imagine if
that was like that [ __ ] came out for
just about a regular guy though and it's
like yeah a regularly showered his
daughter when she was a teen he was like
wait what uh why
I'm sure she's got it under control but
that man and that man was Woody Allen
[Laughter]
Janette McCurdy's mom was [ __ ] uh uh
uh Rodney Dangerfield the Natural Born
Killers Jesus her mom looks like well
now she's dead but in this picture she
looks like Rosie Perez
no she's not dead in that picture well
she's alive in that picture
McCartney is reflecting on her time on
set alleging inappropriate behavior
referring to one figure only as the
Creator
no it's Tyler
yeah I don't know age and that he gave
her a back massage after Sam and Cat was
canceled after one season she okay this
is Good Morning America man you can't
get better audio no okay they're
incapable okay I have a meltdown if my
audio level you know you guys know I
have a meltdown if the audio levels
aren't right and these [ __ ] your
professional News man you're owned by
Disney bro
he writes that Nickelodeon attempted to
arrange a three hundred thousand dollar
thank you partying gift for her only if
she agreed to here's the other point bro
can we bring something up Dan Schneider
goes out there and alleged allegedly
reported Lee molest kids right
and Disney even still cheaped out on
that 300 000.
like really that's the number you throw
bro it doesn't feel like a lot well
because she was she was 18 she's
[ __ ] yeah no I know but I mean
initially even still her mom's the one
that well no it would have been her she
was 18 you know you're right you're
right actually
yeah but still 300 000 like bro you
can't offer her a meal Vince McMahon
paid more to hide legally [ __ ] women
then Nickelodeon paid to try to silence
people that were molested by their
producer
yeah Jeanette you're an idiot have you
seen Christy hemy's House
Jesus Christ ask for more
to never publicly speak about her
experiences at the network it was a gift
she did not accept
social media is already abuzz about
McCurdy's new book some offended by the
title others in complete support the
cover is getting me though dude by the
way can I put the book it's [ __ ]
ridiculous I don't hate it it's actually
funny she's hold okay look I get that
it's bad I got it I know it's disgusting
however Virgie I was not looking at the
cover but you are good she's holding an
earth okay hold on look can we give
Jeanette McCurdy some [ __ ] credit
that's [ __ ] funny
wait wait is there glitter in it yes
the more you look the better it gets
it's filled with like confetti and
glitter
dude I'm not gonna lie man like oh [ __ ]
she is
[ __ ] up yeah I know I know like this
is this is something like a comic would
name their book and have the picture of
right
not Jeanette McCurdy dude this is um
[Music]
people are offended by the book toy I'm
not offended by it it's your life I
think it's in poor taste even if you
hate your mom like I just you know
whatever but oh I agree with you it's
your life but my god dude the title of
that book and her whole vibe lately like
you did you would not want to stick your
dick in this woman so here you go look
who's interviewing her social media
divided over the title why so Direct
you know this title is I get that it's
attention grabbing but it's also
something that I mean sincerely I'm not
saying it at all in a flippant way
and by the way Simon Schuster [ __ ]
published this with this cover but they
won't publish Josh hawley's book no or
Tucker didn't talk or lose no no no
Tucker
Tucker [ __ ] on his book publisher in his
new book for the Josh Hawley yeah in his
new book Simon yeah it was a Simon and
Schuster might have been
while the response might be divided I
really appreciate
the positivity that I received from a
lot of people and the support that I've
received from a lot of people
I think that anybody who has experienced
parental abuse understands this title
and I think anybody who has a sense of
humor understands this title and
amen I'm not so concerned with the
opinion it's your mom you know what I
mean it means of anybody else because
this book is not um for them what do you
think your mom would say about it
I wouldn't have written the book I would
say
wow you look fat
honey you want to take a shower let's
take a shower I'll call Dan she would
grab the book and make me bounce it on
my head to work on my posture that's
what she would do
that's so funny but it's true by the way
can I say her mom does sound like a
[ __ ] nightmare Bro [ __ ] all those
parents were that's a really good point
because you know this is your this is
the younger us covering the Dan
Schneider stuff but something that I
don't think we ever hit hard enough on
was like
the parents that allowed this that
they're [ __ ] I think worse
because like why would you purposely put
your kid through this [ __ ] you know what
I mean and by the way I'm not even
talking about like I'm not even talking
about like potentially being molested
like
even child actors that weren't molested
and [ __ ] even child actors you know no
everyone was fine to me they're still
[ __ ] up being in Hollywood at that age
is [ __ ]
weird it [ __ ] you up even if you don't
get molested you are [ __ ] up forever
like only a couple people have made it
out of like Jason Bateman's one of them
that I could think of off the top of my
head and like a Paul Rudd have made it
out of being child actor but besides
that have you seen what's his face that
from Terminator 2 any females
um
Ariana Grande
not okay though Selena Gomez also broken
okay hold on let me think
I I Hold On
have to be normal that are okay child
actresses that are old because like
honestly Ariana Grande is a [ __ ]
robot
my MB Alec
too ugly to molest yeah that's why but
still but she's made it
doesn't count if nobody wanted to [ __ ]
her
um
yeah man I'm out I think I mean unless
someone in the chat imagine being a
pedophile and you see buying Bialik as a
kid and you're like can you get me one
of them Sprouse twins hey it's six
around
it's a blossom reference rather molest
Joey Lawrence yeah
if my mom were alive there'd be I would
still have my identity dictated by
although man can I say that once you
know a lot of women lie about having
eating disorders
bro now now looking at her here like she
is she's like that really close to being
dangerously skinny right
like she is oh yeah look at the rail the
way the way I always look at it is like
the legs are legs are one way but legs
some some girls just have stick legs it
happens the arms like she's got those
Eugenia Cooney arms yeah like it looks
like her arms are are no thicker than
her wrist
I would still have my identity dictated
by her
did your perspective on your mom change
it all through the writing process oh my
God so much so much
yes sir
I do at times yeah
and I said a lot of things a lot of
Steve has been truly liberating you're
hiding your nerves
I I'm sorry because there's there's a
specific he keeps asking these like
fascinated questions like did your
perspective on your mind oh yeah I'll
play it if you want I mean it's no I'm
sorry it's my you know what I have to
apologize I already listened to it and
she gives like a boilerplate generic
answer all right I I had already like
skimmed through it I just I could
completely forgot where I jotted I had
time stamped a spot that I really that
was actually very interesting but she
does you'll see look watch I think that
anybody who's experienced parental abuse
understands this title and I think
anybody appears in my sadness and she
was abusive
but it simplified in a really relieving
way it now feels like I'm able to just
miss her and I think that is only
possible
because of the healing that happened
through the writing of the book you miss
her your typical you know
I do at times yeah I do at times you
seem so calm about it now what do you
hope people take away from the book
do I sing calm that's great right now so
that's awesome I'm hiding it well
um I I hope people you think you can I
make a prediction here real quick yeah
because I just thought about something
this is going to be her going I'm brave
enough now to go back into acting
what do you think you finally put all my
anger at acting behind me now starting a
new chapter of my chapter right and then
there'll be a new CW Show or something
with her you know garbage yeah
you know I put all of myself into this
book 110 how old is she because like if
she was old enough you call like turning
30 with McCurdy or something like that
yeah tell me that's not a CW [ __ ]
name for a show no she'd probably be on
something with like [ __ ] werewolves
or something because she's already got
that like gaunty frame for the makeup
you know what I mean like a Sci-Fi
version of Twilight yeah
McCurdy's 30s I like him McCurdy's 30s
is good right myself
and I said a lot of things a lot of
uncomfortable truths that are I think
difficult things to say
the more uncomfortable something was for
me to put on the page the more important
it felt for me to put it on the page
that kind of honesty has been truly
liberating for me
yeah it looks like clippy like the
Microsoft the [ __ ] uh um helper clip
yeah
the right Memoir about how much you
hated your [ __ ] mom can I help you
with grammar my favorite was the clippy
one about Boomers where it's like hey I
noticed you're praising Israel and
Social Security would you like you know
engage the caps lock button yes
that was good
and has led me to a life of fulfillment
and authenticity that I hope for
everybody so I hope that people take
away
the honesty and are maybe inspired to
share I like this views has a good point
he goes so you've revealed nothing and
now you can buy your way back in with
leverage okay so that's the thing okay
there's a clip coming up here and that's
actually close to the point I wanted to
make watch those uncomfortable truths
about themselves you know you say you're
hot other people picked it up watch
watch fighting your nerves well running
something that Miranda Cosgrove said she
said you don't expect things like this
from the person in the room who's making
everyone laugh so what's your advice to
people who may seem calm on the outside
may seem funny on the outside but are
struggling inside
write a book and go on Good Morning
America do drugs yeah
you have to make contact with that
struggle I think I really what does that
even mean therapist words therapist
words you listen to therapist words
believe you have to face the parts of
yourself for me facing the parts of
myself that I felt the most Shame about
facing those and becoming public with
those has been really healing for me and
transformative and so I hope
I hope that people consider that for
themselves I mean every I know you keep
we've all said this but she is genuinely
broken like
I really do feel bad for her she is
genuinely just never had a childhood
and and she doesn't know how to be an
adult because of it let's talk about
what happened to Nickelodeon here it is
this is okay
here we go this is actually interesting
uh with this crew person you call the
Creator you say the network offered you
three hundred thousand dollars in hush
money
I have seen some of these headlines I've
seen a lot of headlines about the book
and I'm really glad that the book's
receiving a lot of attention that's
that's awesome that's wonderful
um what I will say is that the book is
so much more than that see now here we
go
it is so I know you're saying it's so
much more than that but
you knew that this would be headline
catching that's why you put it in the
book right
again I really hope you didn't just put
this in there to [ __ ] get the stuff
but you're not going to commit to it
because my my biggest problem with stuff
like this is people that go through this
[ __ ] and don't say anything right and
then the dude goes on and does it to
somebody else right
that's you you got someone's got to stop
it right
my book is so much more it cannot be
reduced to a headline my life nor this
book can be reduced to a headline but
they did offer you the money and you did
turn it down
okay that's fine but today wow slight
slight journalism
I have said everything that I want to
say about that in the book I hope people
you know what I hope that anybody whose
attention might be peaked by these
headlines will will consider reading
give me money the book because I've said
everything in as articulate and
thoughtful of a way as I can manage in
that book I took a year and a half
writing it I did 12 drafts my editor
Sean knows this very well he knows this
very intimately he knows how how hard I
worked on this and he was he was very
instrumental as well but um but I said
everything that I wanted to say there
your brother's going to read it for the
first time Marcus Dustin Scotty you've
dedicated it I said everything I want I
want to say there see this is I don't
like this evasive stuff
this is the stuff I don't like we're
talking about it because we're all
making assumptions but it's just going
to be one of those things we're going to
use as headline bait and she's never
going to talk about it again and it's
going to go away nothing's going to
happen because that's what it's starting
to seem like right yeah no it's just a
sales pitch bro
that's pretty slimy yeah
read a book about how much Jeanette
McCurdy hates her [ __ ] moms so you
can read four lines about how [ __ ]
the Creator touched her [ __ ]
inappropriately
well I will say this
um
we'll see if more stuff comes out I
doubt it